mais Monsieur le Ministre
les femmes qui demandent à revenir elles
le font parce que nous ne les avons pas
déçu de la nationalité française ce que
le Royaume-Uni ce que le Royaume-Uni a
fait à l'égard des djihadistes ce qui
lui permet de ne pas récupérer les gens
retenus en Syrie je me permets de vous
rappeler également que lorsque Nicole
Belloubet été gardé saut en 2019-2020
elle nous disait ici un la France
préfère qu'il y ait des jugements en
Irak avec des tribunaux mixtes et
ensuite elle nous a dit puisque ça n'est
pas faisable dans tous les cas nous
ferons du cas par cas et nous ne ferons
revenir en France que des gens dont nous
saurons qu'il n'y a aucune dangerosité
je vous rappelle que c'était Donald
Trump qu'elle merci Laurent merci le
président Laurent
je vous rappelle que le c'est Donald
Trump qui avait demandé à la France et à
l'Europe de rapatrier ces épouses de
djihadistes et le président Macron à
l'époque avait été répondu pas question
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux pour la
sécurité des Français en quoi la
sécurité des Français en 2022 et
différentes de celle de 2019 surtout
monsieur le garder soit et vous le savez
et c'est bien que la justice s'occupe
des femmes qui reviennent mais la
plupart d'entre elles la plupart d'entre
elles ont continué dans les camps de
détention en Syrie sur les réseaux
sociaux à vanter les mérites de daesh
inventer les mérites des attentats et du
fait de pouvoir continuer la lutte des
djihadistes en France et ailleurs voilà
qui nous avons fait rentrer
merci